今天這堂課非常寶貴
今天會告訴你短中長期
均線真正的運用跟入門喔
月線就是一個短期的
我們看多空的分界
一個向上 一個向下
所以你就不要動了
就我說高手盤不要在這做
你什麼時候做
你又爆爆爆爆爆爆爆爆爆爆
你這兩條線要看懂了
大概很難賠錢
欸 真的嗎
就告訴大家一條
可以掉大魚的線
K線之神要來教我們一套
最好用的均線操作法
完美進場 完美出場
你的獲利可不得了
是10塊 報到70塊
你已經大概70
我會教到你
老師 我發現
最近有一個留言
我覺得很特別
他的意思是
他其實加入我們達人秀很久了
可是其實我們講的啊
他都沒有聽懂
一直到你來他才聽懂所有的東西
對啊 為什麼那麼神啊
因為我是平民
講話比較著名化
其實技術分析
他是一個很簡單的圖
我們用一個簡單的話
把這個圖講清楚了
就很容易聽懂
是不是因為你以前帶兵
兵的口令是要很明確
對 沒有廢話
沒有廢話
一個口令一個動作
那我知道之前來的人都在講廢話
你不要
我要跟你跳
那我的用意是希望
大家都能夠把它學會
學會才是最重要
好 我相信很多人看我們
理財達人秀的標古在線等
都有一個感覺喔
就是 哇 朱老師來了
我終於過去聽不懂的技術分析
我現在全部都聽懂了
趙華是很佩服朱老師
因為趙華10年前認識朱老師的時候
也是這樣開始學的
那今天這堂課非常重要喔
很多人你都會覺得
你至少會看什麼軍線對不對
五日軍啦 十日軍啦 月線啦 季線啦
好像都很耳熟能詳
可是你真的會用嗎
你真的懂得軍線的意義嗎
今天這堂課非常寶貴
今天會告訴你
短中長期軍線真正的運用跟入門喔
所以你對軍線有疑問
或是你對軍線
你自己以為自己很熟的
今天要聽朱老師講這堂課
所以今天我們來講軍線
可是軍線很多條
所以老師要先告訴我們
什麼樣的軍線
俗話有一句話講
放長線 釣大魚
對 那今天就告訴大家一條
可以釣大魚的線
一條而已嗎
對 一條線就可以了
一條線就可以了
這條線可以讓你釣到大魚
不是這條魚
老師 釣到船會沈
這魚太大了
也夠你吃好幾倍了
好幾倍的魚都可以吃了
對
那這條線我們叫做均線
一條均線
其實均線有很多年齡的差別
有五天的 有十天的
有短的 中的 長的
但總之均線非常好用
沒錯
我們看這張圖
這裡有一條均線叫月線
月線就是二十日線
二十日線
那等一下我們會告訴你
它怎麼算出來的
好
那我又看到一檔股票
一檔股票在月線上跑
那我來問問你
如果這個股票在月線上
你要怎麼買
我要怎麼買
問我嗎
你要賺錢就要買
不買怎麼賺錢
我是十年前上你的課
不是現在
所以我要看看
你實驗有沒有進步
還是十年前
沒有進步
我已經被骨魚跟老王帶壞了
好 我來試試看
我來試試看好不好
一個股票在漲要怎麼買
我告訴你老師
你就是太老實了
其實你已經把我做安好了
真的
你也不見得會對
也許我會陷害你的
你不要貼錯
我告訴你我什麼時候買
我當然就是第一個上去我就要買
對不對
還有呢
然後再來
我覺得這個地方很吊詭
這個地方應該要買
他都已經橫盤整理了對不對
對
我要買
好
第三個啊
還有一個 很會漲
很會漲喔
可是這邊已經漲高了耶
對啊
那我就先買在這裡好了啦
對這樣子
因為你看觸到線往上談
我買我一定賺啊
對 到華三個買點
說起來很容易
那是因為事後論
圖已經長上來了
所以你都看得到
對 那實際上這三個買點
的確也是三個買點
真的嗎 對
來 我們來看一下
在趨勢裡面
我有跟大家講
我們在做多的時候
其實這三個買點只有兩個買點
其實我們多頭只有兩個買點
這兩個買點如果你用口語話的話
一個叫做回後買上漲
回後買上漲
這個有回檔吧
回檔就下跌
下跌以後你去買它上漲的這一根
所以老師的意思是
它還是要在月線的上面
對重點就是我們今天要講的這條線
不能掉在這條線的下面
下面掉到月線下
我們就不做多了
第二個位置叫盤整的突破
好
如果你有看到盤整
你就要準備做這一支股票
那它總有一天會突破
那你要做多
所以當然做突破
不會去做跌破
對不對 跌破就不會做多了
所以一樣它盤整
要在月線上的盤整
對 然後回後買上張
那這樣子我們就是很簡單
如果趨勢是多頭
在月線上 月線又在往上
只做多不做空
但是老師我剛剛沒有貼
這個是因為他都漲這麼多了
我還要再買
股票裡面有句話嘛
強者很強
月強的股票他就是月強
那只要你跟著他走
因為他沒有Deport月線
你不必擔心啊
你還可以繼續做
然後你做了以後
Deport月線你就賣了
你也不會說
讓他一直疊一直疊
好像很簡單
對 這就叫紀律
是不是
如果有紀律實在是很簡單
老師你可以舉個例子嗎
月線 光靠一條月線
我可以賺多長的破斷
我們來看
我們先說
第一個你做多一定要多頭
對不對
所以你看這個地方多頭
是不是確認了
這一檔啊
對
我們很熟耶
真的
因為我們有一個叫全正小哥
跟我的第一次相遇
我們的初戀服
就是這一檔
那時候50塊
好 那我們他50塊有回來過修正
修正完了在這個地方
他又重新轉成多頭
那趨勢我們以後還是會介紹給大家
你就很清楚
這邊多頭確認你是不是要開始做多了
是 這時候你就去抓月線
這條月線是紅的
月線是紅色這一條
其實有很多條線
我們等一下一條條講
你就抓好了
抓好了就像剛才這個趙華的買點
是 回後買上漲
回後買上漲
然後走到高點你就賣了一趟
好
回後買上漲
你又走了一趟
然後回後
這個KK跌破了
回後買上漲
你又大賺一趟
我怎麼可能知道這邊要賣
他沒有跌破月線
這邊KK跌破五軍
這個做短
好做短
等一下會告訴大家還有五枚軍線
但是他都沒有跌破月線
所以你可以決定沒有跌破錢你要不要走
對
好
如果你做短現在又來了
回後買上漲
又大賺
然後回後買上漲 你叫小賺
好 那剛才趙華問的一個問題
那請問你在這個地方的時候
已經四百多塊了
會不會很高了
你這邊欺負幾塊
我不能被你騙
高也要看是什麼傾向
也有一檔到兩千塊的
對啊
所以我們還是剛才那個紀律
月線沒有跌破
趨勢沒有改變
我以後買上漲
我還是買啊
總之不管多少錢
現行沒有破就是沒有破
然後我還是按紀律賣
所以你還是沒有賠
如果你不按紀律
這一趟就賠很多了
因為它一直疊
所以老師這邊是疊破月線
其實是一定要出對不對
對 一定要出
OK嗎
所以我們先把月線跟區是
結合起來看
兩個結合在一起
我相信各位就很容易了
那均線的概念是什麼
因為像我們之前講KD
我講MACD都有教大家
它的概念是什麼
均線概念是什麼呢
我們對均線概念
就是一個平均成本的意思
平均成本
我們來看
假如我這裡是一條五日均線
五日均線
如果我的股價在下面
就是比五日均線要低的話
表示這五天
你買的人是賠錢的
所以跌破五日均線
就代表過去五天買的人
現在賠錢了
所以叫短
五天嘛 所以很短
一週
那如果今天一下子開盤跳空
就到五日均線上面了
那就是一 二 這五天買的人賺錢
都賺錢囉
因為你的平均成本
已經被突破了 你就賺錢了
很簡單的概念就是
我們用一個圖駕圖給你算一下
你就知道了
比如說我今天收盤了
那我收盤是不是有一條五日均線
那這個五日均線你就會發現
這個五日均線不是
48.19
怎麼算出來的 對不對
對 你怎麼會來的
這個五日均先就是
一天 兩天 三天 四天 五天
收盤價 每天都有收盤價
你加起來除以五
就48.19
那請問一下明天是不是有新的
因為明天又有收盤價
然後你再加四天
然後你又算出一個
新的 49.6
然後你把這個點再連起來
這樣子五日軍線就一直在跑
所以這個叫移動平均線
移動平均線
因為它每一天會因為新的收盤價
來做改變
是收盤價
每天的收盤價
這樣子就算出五日軍線
好不好
所以五日這樣算 十日這樣算
月線 季線 年線都是這樣算出來的
都是這樣算
那十日就十天了
你就算十天
那我們剛剛這樣算
你大概就有概念了
五日軍線就是五天的
收盤的平均成本
所以它是一個平均成本的概念
但是有很多條線
老師你看我們隨便打開一個軟體
假設叫出一檔股票
五日均線 十日均線
二十日均線 六十日 一百二十兩百四十日
線太多了
剛剛老師有先講一個月線
但這些線那麼多我要怎麼看
我們現在來看這張圖
各位就可以看一下它的重點
這條五日均線
各位看這邊是不是疊了兩天
對 然後五日式這個深紅色的
你就發現五日軍線就開始彎了
它就開始下彎
它就開始彎了
它反應比較快
對 然後這邊疊了很久
所以十日軍線也彎了
也開始彎了
那這邊疊的更久
一直疊 你看月線也彎了
二十日的這邊這個紫紅色的也開始彎了
二十日也彎了
所以我們從不同的軍線
就會知道說
短軍線是看短的骨架的變化
是 骨架疊短均線就會彎
那長均線呢
我們剛剛有講月線叫方向嘛
所以你這邊疊破了
這邊都不能操作了
你已經月線已經下彎了
所以長線你不能做了
那什麼時候做
等它再上來
所以這個地方又可以開始做了
好 均線又開始往上跑了
對 月線又開始往上跑了
但是要月線或季線往上跑
也是要比較長的趨勢
要長的時間 來改變
他要改變也是要很長的時間
改變方向
那他要改成像上也要很長的時間
那這一段就是我們要等的時候
所以不用急
股票市場不是每天都可以操作的
當你該要等的時候你一定要等
等到機會來
你就很容易賺到破斷
那一個大的破斷
老師上次我們錄MACD的時候
你都不停的警告照黃
我就是做太短
所以沒關係
我現在要接近神的領域
主老師那如果是你的話
你會覺得比較主要看
什麼樣的線
你要做長也不要一檔
報到年紀老
什麼年紀老
不要報好幾年
那是成古吧
成古會年紀老
對
那誰要退休金的年紀
好 我們來看一下
基本上我們用月線
作為你一個多空分界就可以了
月線 季線其實對老師來說
更重要
為什麼呢
一般來說月線是短期操作的多空分界
那我們剛才那張圖多頭在月線上
你就可以一直做多
你就因為他在月線上
月線是一個月的平均成本
這個月買的人都在賺錢
但是月線老師還是認為是短期的多空
所以我們在日線操作
你就把月線看好
月線不要跌破就好了
如果各位想做更長一點的
就把季線作為多空分界
只要季線不要彎頭
你就可以一直爆
爆到它季線彎了
那趨勢當然一定是一個空頭了
因為這是中期嘛
因為有人說季線是生命線
沒錯
也就是我們講的比較長一點的趨勢改變
那我們在這裡兩句話
請你特別注意一下就好了
只要你不要犯了這個規
你應該在股票市場
就平平安安的
第一個趨勢多頭在月線上
只多不做空
月線上揚的情況
還有多頭在月線上的時候
做多不做空
趨勢空頭在月線下
你就只做空不做多
這兩個大方向你抓到了
基本上你在股票市場
應該已經算是很厲害了
而且還算是高手
還算是高手
為什麼
因為你要在月線上
我剛剛有講
打底的時候你就不會做
因為月線沒上來
所以你不會做
一般人都會很急著要做
那大概就是初學的
剛學的看到股票長就想說
所以我又講
你這兩條線要看懂了
然後你在很穩定的狀態下
去找進場機會
實際上你是股票高手
因為你大概很難賠錢
所以其實我初進場
我先學月線跟季線這兩條
尤其是月線對不對
月線最重要
我就可以做到一個比較大的波段
很大的波段
再加上配合好趨勢
趨勢多頭
基本上你在股票上
你已經很厲害
好 可是多頭要怎麼看
我們來看一下
我們先來看趨勢
我把剛才講的
剛剛有講月線跟季線的趨勢
那兩句話
各位把它看長一點
你就很清楚了
好 我們來看
這個是不是月線向下
月線是這條紫紅色的線
月線 然後季線是這條
這條上面的橘色的線
你看這兩條線向下
是不是一路都在走空
真的很空
你怎麼抱 而且抱很久
對
好 那現在問題來了
一個向上 一個向下
所以你就不要動了
就我說高手盤不要在這做
你不要做 你什麼時候做
月線上來 季線上來
你又抱抱抱抱抱抱抱抱抱
這一檔其實我覺得應該
update到最近
最近有點狀況
最近你又會看月線彎
月線已經彎了
老師已經預言了 短期
短期它已經開始你要退了
要退出來
可是你一報就報這麼長
這你一報就報這麼長
報到700多
也賺夠了
說真的 也賺夠了
這個如果你看懂
這條月線跟季線
在股市裡面
應該是屬於高手了
所以老師我覺得我很認同
因為像我們都是600多才進場
現在不知道怎麼辦
也可以報到700多
現在彎回來了
好 像我們再複習一下
因為多頭排列其實軍線是要排隊的
對 要排隊的
要從短中長去排
而且軍線 太整齊了
軍線都向上
不會啊 等一下你看毒
你看毒都很整齊的
因為它只要是好的多頭
這個就排排站
對
就跟你講的軍隊裡面
都訓練好的
它都排得好的
然後你又在上面
那為什麼要這樣子
他對你大有幫助
好 所以就是從五日
一直排到可能半年線 年線
排排站 難怪朱老師
軍令盧山請他們排隊
其實你用我們剛才講的邏輯
你去想一下
我短線跌破五軍了
那你說我想報場一點
沒關係 下面有個實軍幫你撐
因為越長的軍線支撐就越強
因為他的累積的時間越長
對不對 他每一天的
十天的交易
那我如果實均跌破
我還有20均啊
我有一個月買的人在幫我撐著
這個月買的人都在下面
那我股價在上面
所以他會幫我撐著
老師 可他會變成一個
我不停損的藉口
那就是你進場就要決定
這支股票
我們做長做短
你在進場的時候就要決定
而不是要出場的時候去決定
這句話很有助理喔
因為你出場的時候決定
你就會一直往後
一直往後延
所以你就不賣
到跌破連線了
已經賠了一大堆了
但是月線是老師
你覺得手的一個觀察
沒錯
對
我以我的經驗
一般的投資人
除非很專業的
那種像投信那種很專業的
一般的投資人
你把月線手好就可以
而且你的獲利也很好
非常的好
好 那我們來看一下
一定要六條線都排起來嗎
那我們做一個短線吧
三線就好了
最少三條
三條線就好了
這叫最基本的要求
最基本的要求
換句話說你沒有三線多牌
你不要做啦
這是最基本的
三線是50 20
那20跑不掉的
一定要有20
所以我們來看一下
這個地方在打底的時候
你看這個20都在往下
對 這邊是下彎的
20是下彎的
然後趨勢變多了
對不對
那這時候你再去看
這三條線擺好了沒有
五均 十均
二十均喔
好了 可以了
那你要做短
就是跌破5均
對不對
站上5均
跌破5均
這是做短的
那你要做20了
到最後還沒有賣
對
你還在包
甚至做10的都還沒有賣
也沒賣 都沒有賣
對不對
所以可以賺比較大一波
沒錯
換句話講
你要從這個地方開始做
你不要在這裡做
這裡因為均線沒做好
這邊均線根本沒有排列整齊
但往上真的很乖
就50 20排得好好的
要不就排得好好的嗎
那之後你就可以做了
而且這個排列我一直跟大家講
我們做股票很輕鬆
因為這個排列是有人幫你排好的
有人幫我排好
不是你排的
不是我排的
不是朱老師下令
你沒有這個
我也沒這個本事
因為市場很大
對不對
你看隨便一個股本都是幾百億
我們怎麼可能去排
其實是有利的資金
金庫之後會讓他排好
有很多可能外資
三大法人
他們會幫你排好
所以我們就減現成的
這樣就好了
好 雖然趙華做比較短
但是剛剛趙華有看到半年線季線
年線這麼長的線
所以他們也來排代表什麼
其實這一張圖是最具代表意
就是他中美金
短中長你都會看懂
是
那我們剛剛講做短線要怎樣
三線羅牌
對
這個地方各位就
你看是不是很乖
50 26條啊
所以說你不要說
我沒有看過6條牌的那麼整齊的
他很考驗那個對顏色的辨別
這種有點深紅色 淺藍色 桃紅色
橘色 灰色 藍色
他自己對 六條線
就六條嘛
你一看就有六條
這是事後論嘛
你說我現在要開始做了
那你做短可不可以
可以啊
可以啊 我已經三千多排
我已經三千多排了
所以你看做短
上漲 下跌 上漲 下跌 上漲 下跌
上漲 下跌 上漲 下跌
跌破五均喔
跌破十均喔
所以你不會買
然後這邊頭頭低
所以這一段你不會做
為什麼
因為五均 十均趨勢改了
你都不會做
月線也下彎了 你都不會做
那意思等等等等
又來了 五均 十均 二十均
然後這邊可以看很清楚
這根紅K
我又來了
上漲 下跌
回後買上漲
回後買上漲 回後買上漲
然後跌破五均 六買
老師到後來這幾條像裝飾用
是啊 所以長線你就會發現
根本用不到後面三條
你只要前面四條到季線
季線也沒碰到
季線都還沒跌破
所以我剛剛講月線就夠用
月線就夠用
老師那你可以幫我們
因為看到這個啊
我覺得我的青春都等老了
你們能幫我們整理
就是說如果我今天是短中長期
我們等一下來做個統整
好不好 因為講那麼多條線
我幫你整理一下了
那如果各位要做一個超短期的
現在很多都要當沖
現在當沖啊
每天的交易都一直創新高
幾乎四成的
他要接近四成
每天都當沖
那我在這裡先說明一下
做股票沒有說短線好長線好
會賺錢就好
只要會賺錢
費他老鼠的就好
所以即使是當沖
老師也覺得沒關係
沒問題啊
我也交當沖啊
交到你每天都賺啊
因為當沖是天天沖嘛
所以我會教到你日盡萬斤
一天賺一萬夠用了吧
夠用
我們改上當沖好不好
因為你早上沖
下午就可以花一萬
晚上也可以花
我現在製作人眼睛亮起來
當沖就是早上8點
8點半進場
然後10點半下班
就沖完了嘛
所以也很好啊
我們先不要教
等一下製作人跑了
對
其實做長做短都有好
都很好
如果你做當沖
很多人做一分K的
一分線
一分K
一分鐘的
一分鐘的K線
也有五軍十軍二十軍
老師下次我們真的就來講一集好了
因為老師教當沖我放心了
其實有很多人想上達人秀教當沖
但趙華沒有接受
因為當沖還是需要一個
很好的技術和技術
但是朱老師趙華放心
所以我們會請朱老師
來教我們當沖好不好
以後
台車很多機會
那你如果當沖 你就是用1分K的均線
5分K 15分 60分K的均線
OK 那我們正常的做股票
像趙華說你做短線
就是5日 10日就可以了
那這邊寫個3日是給誰用的
是 如果趙華你做到標股
你就要3日
我做到標股 要3日
什麼叫標股 連續漲3天
你都獲利30%以上
也就是一整天
不是 一天10 也就是漲幅就10%
他就連三天
標股不是就連續標
漲停三天
你有二三十趴了
你就不要去守武軍了
守三日軍
所以三日軍是一個比較
特殊標長的時候
其實你做正常股票
我們都有聽說陌生段
陌生段都是標的
那之後你要跑快一點
所以你就要三日
守三日
對 那正常我們就五日
這樣OK
OK的
好 那你如果要做長一點
就我們剛剛講的月線
你去守月線
那季線真的很長了
我們剛才中美金做了
一年多都沒破季線
那就非常的長
季線是60天的平均
那更長一點
其實這個是在周線做的
去周線裡面守20均
周到20均大概就100天
那這個大概就幾乎在守半年線
那像剛才照他講
根本看不到半年線
用不到半年線
而且我們用圖去看
跌到半年線
你是不是跌很深
太慘了 根本就是大空頭了
沒錯 那換優化長
你前面一連轉了300%
還他100%
因為他跌到半年線
大概要回來1.3 甚至於1.2
那這樣在操作上是不太實用
所以我們的K線之審
要來教我們一套
最好用的均線操作法
我們一直講操作不要太複雜
因為太複雜你很難去動作
我們選股可以複雜一點
你看我們要看均線
看K線 看KD 看MACD
對 交這麼多
它是為了讓你選股的
你選一支好股票
當你的好股票選到了
你進場了 請你越簡單越好
對不對
那我們最簡單的方法
就找一條均線就好了
所以你就用單一的均線
這條均線找好了
你把你的進場的紀律守好
續報的序率
然後停損 然後什麼時候停力
出場就停力嘛
你把這四個都做好
基本上你這個操作
就很簡單的獲利了
好 所以我們要怎麼樣做到這四點
對 完美進場 完美出場
我們剛剛講你用五軍嘛
收盤錢確認站上五軍
然後收盤錢還是收盤後
收盤錢 收盤後就要明天啦
明天沒關係 那明天你會追高啊
他如果開盤漲
開盤漲停板你就買不到了
所以老師的意思是
比如說我要1.20分左右
1.20分以後
你就要開始決定了
因為你還有五分鐘
再去看他
再檢查一下
好緊張喔
因為你還沒有進場
你的錢還沒有掏出來
那1.10分可以嗎
可以
其實1.以後
這支股票應該已經成型了
1.以後
就像趙華剛貼了幾個位置
你到1.中已經出來了
你就準備要貼下去
就準備把錢要丟下去
這邊也解答很多網友的疑問
1.以後我們來找進場點
因為我一直不太鼓勵剛學的人在盤中進
因為你可能
為什麼不都要在盤中進
因為你還不會當充
盤中進是當充人在用
這個我們以後來講
當充才要盤中進
對不對
那我們正常交易嘛
你又不是要做短
你至少要抱三五天
你不要計較說
找一檔或者玩一檔
我要賺這個8%到10%嘛
所以你進場要很重要一個觀念
我們叫確認
因為你確認你的機率才高
表示成功了
他已經完成了
所以收盤前確認
一點鐘再來下單囉
然後停損就是
你進場的最低點不要跌破
我進場的最低點
你已經確認這根紅K要買了
那你進去啦
那明後天這個紅K的最低點
不要破掉
紅K的最低點不要破
也是收盤不要跌破
看到收盤
然後再來你就準備賺錢了
那什麼狀況你就不能賣
有的時候你賣早了也少賺
你也很歐對不對
這還滿常發生
其實這個發生就是因為你在盤中
盤中去看
不要看對不對
對
要這個要磨
你不要去看盤
什麼時候看就是一點
一點鐘看真的跌破了
你就賣 但是沒有你就爆
我覺得這樣很棒
早上我可以上班嗎
沒錯
午餐時間再來看
再來看
你就覺得 哇 原來10點鐘有殺下去
可是你沒賣 對不對
你就撿到啦 對不對
就不會被盤中的波動給干擾
我們就要把它被洗掉了
那最後當然你1點20 25分
再看都確認了 它上不來了
那我們就把它買
好 所以老師的意思是
其實我們也是1點之後
再確定要不要出場
對...
就算你出場也要派出
這個好重要喔
對 很重要
像我都是8點半
從試搓開始看
我就是很容易心情波動
試說更是容易作假
有
這個我們全正小哥有一集試說
對試說怎麼作假
可以去看
試說要看最後兩分鐘
前面都白看
對
一開始就掛掌停板
小哥說看最後兩秒鐘
最後要開板的時候
挖碟停板
沒錯
試說我們有交理整集
試說不用去看
好 那我們就剛剛講簡單的方法
但是這你還是一樣
有幾個很重要的觀念
是
不要做錯了
好
用於多頭區是明確
所以盤整區不要用
好
盤整很多東西其實都不要用
都不用用
都一樣指標也是不要用
對不對
但是你不用盤整
可是你不要忘了
盤整突破可是好位置
盤整突破可能會有大波段
你不要賺錢
對不對
剛才趙華貼的有一個位置
就是盤整突破
對
沒錯
第二個做多維持趨勢不變
二十軍一定要向上
要微向往上
對 一定要往上
這樣OK
換句話講你看他往下
你就趕快跑嘛
你就不要做了
月線下彎就趕快跑走了
那做空 空頭趨勢不能變
這個月線要下彎
要不開心的感覺
對 然後你就一直空他就好了
好像有點落井下石
越不開心越空
就是要這樣
他真的很符合人性嘛
上彎就是快開心的嘛
下彎就是這檔股票不開心嘛
不開心就空
無論進出這邊有再強調
收盤價確認
收盤價 但是老師的收盤價
是指一點以後
一點以後不是說真的收盤囉
一點二十一點二十五分
真的收盤要等隔天
對
然後日線 週限都可以
當然你做週限的人是長線
你要等到週末
收盤再確認
要等確認嘛
對 你要等收盤
好
好 那我們這邊也有講短線用5均
中線用10均
長線用20均就可以了
對 好 所以這個再來跟大家複習一次喔
用月線20的均
我們用20就是做長的
這邊一樣啊 多頭要先確認
好 多頭先確認喔
回後買上漲 回後買上漲
回一檔又上漲
你買今天買明天都沒有關係
我講過 不要計較這個
就是你要確認它
它有大量 有紅K
收盤過了昨天K線的高點
老師 但是你這上面只有20日
所以我還需不需要搭配
5日10日也都是要多投牌練
你再做20啊
我就只看20
我不用三線了
我在20均 要20均上揚
只要它是回後買上漲就可以買
買了以後你現在手20囉
所以你才賣
這中間有沒有疊 有啊
有 但是沒有疊過
但是因為你手20
所以你就只做了一波
各位不要看這一波
這一波就8月 9月
你報一個多月
可是你的獲利可不得了
40塊報到70塊
你已經大概70%
大概7成
OK
這個短短的一個20均
好 那你說
我真的不太敢報
太好了 變10均了
我沒有10均來
就短多了吧
可是你獲利不會少
一樣跌破10均
站上十均 跌破十均
站上十均 跌破十均 賣
所以你這邊小賠
這就記憶率
你的距離跌破你就要賣
賣完了
你就賺了一趟
賺了兩趟
剛才做一趟 現在做兩趟
所以老師我進場跟出場
我手同一條線嗎
例如說我是站上十日進場
那我就是跌破十日出場
但是很多人會
我站上五日進場
我跌破月線我才出場
這也是問題對不對
對也是問題啦
因為你也不也話去話講
你站上五日去買
那你是要做短線嘛
是
可是這個短線如果走得很漂亮
你也可以做成長線
哦
那等一下我們講做長線的一個
最重要的關聯
做長線其實是從短線做出來的
哦 不可能天生
所以我可以短線進場包到長線
對 你不可能天生進來
就是一條長線嘛
我們講長線是後面走出來的
好
OK 讓好
所以我們短線進場
那這個跟十軍跟二十軍
你就明顯的區別
十軍做了兩次
沒錯 中間有出場的點
二十軍做一次
沒錯 沒有破線
好 現在是五日軍囉
就軍團的中線囉
剛才我講五日嘛
跌破五日
進場 跌破五日
出場 站上五日
進場 跌破
好忙喔
這邊跌破出場 站上
跌破
你做了四五場
有點忙
對 所以短線進出就是交易比較頻繁
而且也不見得賺比較多
你的交易成本比較高
基本上來說
長線當然你的獲利比較高
剛才一趟就70%
但短線
我們有一個概念就是說
短線叫分期付款
我一起一起拉
一起一起的賺
你這邊分了五期給我
那我月線一次付款
從頭到尾一次收
那個叫一次
所以整個交易的手續費會很低就對了
對
那這個問題就是看你個人
因為有人個性疊一天都怕
那你叫他疊三天他不是嚇死而...
心情會很長
這也是一個問題
所以大家要了解自己的個性
自己的個性
所以在市場才說嘛
100個人有110個做法
每個人的做法都不一樣
因為有人有兩三套做法
沒錯 沒錯
就是你自己適合
這一點最重要了
最後呢
不好意思喔
因為朱老師講的喔
我相信今天看完
你的收穫一定非常多
均線你一定完全了解了
但是均線一樣
它有一些背後的意義
我們會放在精英班
先讓大家也是一樣
聞香一下 品香一下喔
有所謂的真突破跟假突破
怎麼說呢
因為我們剛剛有講說
均線會多牌嗎
但是均線也會有短均穿越長均
好 這是不是叫黃金交叉
不一定喔
有的是真的 有的是假的喔
有的是黃金 有的可能是憤途
那怎麼分辨
我們等一下菁英斑會來告訴你
那這邊一樣
要來謝謝加入我們
菁英斑還有榮耀斑的會員們
趙華非常感謝你們
因為很多人有告訴趙華
其實他看的
不一定是裡面的課程
因為我們的課程
因為他很濃縮
他也要學習
他不會非常的大量
但是他是為了支持
我們理財單位秀
所以來加入
因為他很怕
這麼好的節目
會不會哪一天
經費不足就沒有了
謝謝你
真的很喜歡你們
所以趙華來感謝
這位林子森
他是專程為了朱老師
朱老師說的前嫌易懂
原本對KD技術指標已經要放棄了
到現在是被老師一言點行
然後這個
他的名字裡面有個聲
何鴻生的聲
他說謝謝趙華跟朱家宏老師
已經加入菁英班囉 超級實用
然後這個應該叫做Charlene
他說為了趙華跟朱老師
我加入會員囉
重點好多
希望我可以抓到好買點
哇 我們每一集朱老師的每一堂課
都在教你抓好買點
好 今天這堂課
五日到年限
五日去到年限都教你了
但是朱老師有特別佛心的告訴你
如果你真的是初入門初學者
先學哪一條呢
先學二十日月線
月線是一個短期的生命多空線
所以朱老師剛才也把月線
怎麼操作都告訴大家
當然如果你跟趙華一樣
很怕青春等老了
五日時日也是很好運用
所以今天這一集相信你
對均線已經非常了解
我們下次再見 拜拜